show me the money or in this case show
us the baby the Dutchess of Sussex
herself let slip that she was due at the
end of April beginning of May well here
we are and here's why we think baby
Sussex has already arrived
for starters virgin radio show host
Chris Evans teased us Tuesday morning
with what sounds like insider
information what do you think you know
I'll tell you after today's next up the
Duchess have been m.i.a
since March 11 Commonwealth day was
Duchess Megan's last official engagement
in the diary while she will be doing
private meetings and working up pretty
much until her due date we're probably
not going to see Megan out on an
official engagement until after that
royal baby is born and considering it's
been almost two months since we last saw
mm it seemed safe to assume she is
already given birth and is busy
adjusting to motherhood
out of the public eye in the meantime
our favorite ginger has been making
unscheduled solo appearances on Sunday
he dropped by the London Marathon for a
surprise visit earlier in the week you
joined Kate Middleton for an Anzac Day
service and of course Harry attended
Easter Sunday service sans Megan the
biggest hint might be the Queen's
reported visit to Frogmore cottage on
Easter Sunday let's face it the monarch
isn't exactly in the habit of just
dropping by
jeez william and kate's stopped by - and
according to a royal source so did a
number of family members
who'da tended Easter service at the
nearby st. George's Chapel Megan's mom
Doria Ragland is our next piece of
evidence that baby's Sussex has debuted
it's all systems go we knew she was
expected in London for her grandchild's
birth and et has learned that as of
Easter Sunday
Doria has been in London this brings us
to make in super-secretive birth plan
she's allowed to do what she wants
talking having a baby but it has
definitely alienated the press three
weeks ago the palace released this
statement quote the Duke and Duchess
look forward to sharing the exciting
news with everyone once they have had an
opportunity to celebrate privately as a
new family we also learned there won't
be a post baby photo op they plan to
release a couple of photographs to the
media a couple of days after the baby's
born
when mum and baby are feeling up to it
now here's the latest royal news on
Wednesday the palace announced Terry's
upcoming trip to the Netherlands on may
8th and 9th and Charles and Camilla are
leaving for Germany on may 7th which
makes us wonder if they've already been
introduced to sweet baby Sussex it's a
new challenge it's a new chapter now on
Thursday ET learned that Harry's trip
was planned more than a year ago and the
source adds that he will cancel the trip
at the last minute if necessary but
we're not convinced the royal baby isn't
here one more clue as the at Sussex
Royals big Instagram purge on Wednesday
Harry and Megan's account abruptly
unfollowed 7 out of 23 royal accounts
including a willing Kate's account at
Kensington Royal according to their most
recent post the Sussex duo did so in the
name of Mental Health writing quote each
month we will honor this same concept
and change the accounts we solely follow
based on a different theme or cause
the move felt like a way to distract the
press we are on the edge of our seats
anxiously awaiting the arrival of baby
soccer no matter what we can't wait to
get our first glimpse of the newest
royal baby
[Music]